my favorite people on the planet the
Osborn's 15 years after they said
goodbye to their hit reality show are
they ready for a post quarantine
comeback I asked them about that and how
they're holding up during quarantine in
an exclusive interview
how cool is to be together well I've
been this together with my family in
about 50 but I can't really complain I
love my family and there's a good reason
Kellie moved home after all these years
mercs we started filming celebrity watch
party here in order for me to do that I
either have to spend six days a week in
complete isolation so that I can be in a
room with my dad for one day a week or I
move back in with my family and I moved
back in and I I have to say we've been
having a really good time yeah we have
tonight they'll help critique another
week of TV highlights on Fox's celebrity
watch party but the big question will
Aussie stay awake he pretty much slept
through he is this the first step and
you guys bringing the family back to TV
the nightmare continues I haven't even
told you but now you've mentioned it we
can either confirm or deny anything at
this point and that's all we shall say
sure sounds like that could be yes and
while hunkering down at home they also
got a chance to check out Shaq's epic
Ozzy dance-off
I had to watch it like five times
because I couldn't believe what I don't
like
No excuse my language hey is Shaq doing
that with his family we love em some
more great news today on the talk Sharon
in the ladies helps announce the Daytime
Emmy nominees outstanding talk show
entertainment on to talk it means a lot
it's not just for us it's but you know
your crew the producers takes the team
you know it sure does and we kind of
like the way this sounds standing
entertainment news show Entertainment
Tonight what an honor to be nominated
congratulations to everyone in our
Entertainment Tonight family and all the
other nominees by the way the 47th
Annual Daytime Emmy Awards make their
primetime return on June 26th on CBS
[Music]